voglio cominciare con questa citazione
che è attribuita a leonardo da vinci non
sono marci trovare la sorgente vera però
mi piace la uso e lui parla appunto dice
per sviluppare una mente completa studia
la scienza dell'arte e l'arte della
scienza sviluppo i tuoi sensi impara
soprattutto a vedere
comprendi che tutto è connesso questa
frase che non è interessante per una
serie di aspetti questa idea che l'arte
e la scienza come the vede lui che
potremmo trasporre in un linguaggio più
moderno tra come il design la tecnologia
sono due temi che che non può che non
vanno trattati separatamente come se
fossero due cose completamente avulsa
vanno trattate assieme vanno pensate
vanno viste assieme e in questa
intersezione e si creda delle delle
opportunità molto grandi in questo
momento soprattutto mi piace la frase
dove lui dice comprendi che tutto è
connesso per quello che sta succedendo è
qui e un guru abbastanza popolare
insomma in questo in questo secolo
questa idea della interconnessione fra
la tecnologia e il design si creda delle
opportunità specialmente perché il
nostro mondo è già fatto intorno a noi
di digitale di tecnologia digitale è
fatto di internet è sempre più quello
che facciamo è in qualche maniera
connesso in qualche modo legato al mondo
di internet precede che adesso si crea
questa nuova opportunità questa nuova
frontiera di quando gli oggetti
cominciano ad essere anche loro oggetto
di giorni connessi a internet
questo è un braccialetto che traccia
l'attività fisica che faccio io ne ho
uno addosso si funziona anche da
orologio però questa è una delle
funzioni siamo più banali quello che fa
e che misura la quantità di movimento
che faccio
guarda che attività faccio mi mi ricorda
in qualche maniera
qual è la quantità di attività fisica
che faccio la stessa azienda fa per
esempio questa bilancia che la classica
bilancia che si tiene diciamo in casa
però queste wifi è connessa ogni volta
che ci si pesa l'informazione viene
mandata a un server su internet dove a
un certo punto si crea questo cruscotto
che permette di vedere tutte queste
attività legate alla nostra persona che
vengono in qualche maniera rappresentate
no con delle visualizzazioni grafiche
che ci permettono di capire se non ci
muoviamo abbastanza se stiamo in qualche
maniera ci permette di monitorare la
nostra vita con dei numeri è quello che
gli inglesi chiamano conti five self in
qualche maniera la capacità di
quantificare di misurare se stessi
questo si basa sull'idea anche qui un
simbolo semplicissimo oggetto che è
connesso a internet ea questo punto ci
permette in qualche di aggregare queste
informazioni
ci sono adesso sempre di più di questi
oggetti come questa che è una
semplicemente una semplicissima presa
che però ci permette di comandarla si
collega alla rete il 3 di casa ci si può
comandare da comunque parte del mondo
tramite un telefono ma anche un sito web
ma anche in altri modi
anche qui queste queste tecnologie
diventano così piccole che finiscono
dentro una presa oppure una lampada come
questa questa è una lampada che messa in
casa propria
comunica con tante versioni più piccole
di se stessa in casa dei nostri amici
ogni volta che accendiamo e spegniamo
questa lampada tramite internet questa
avverte tutte le piccole lampade casa
nostri amici e gli dice e le fa spegnere
accendere in qualche maniera io posso
comunicare con i miei amici in giro per
il mondo senza usare le parole ma
semplicemente facendo vedere quando io
sono in una stanza non si dà una certa
luce per cui in qualche maniera come un
contatto umano tramite internet ramento
qualcosa di molto semplice di mosti
molto poco tangibile quello che si
estende anche cose tipo questo questo è
un cappuccio per un coperchio per le
barattoli delle medicine che anche lui è
connesso a internet e ci ricorda al
paziente quando è il momento di prendere
una certa pastiglia e monitorizza che
effettivamente il paziente prenda
questa pastiglia in qualche maniera può
aiutare a monitorare se una persona
effettivamente sicura come sicura quali
sono i modi in cui fa queste cose
oppure ci sono queste lampadine ognuna
di queste lampadine a led contiene al
suo interno una piccola radio che gli
permette anche lì di essere connessa con
intere per cui io posso comandare alle
luci di casa per ogni singola lampada e
individualmente controllabile
queste tecnologie cominciano a diventare
così piccole che le infiliamo dentro una
lampadina oppure questo è un prodotto
abbastanza famoso questa jenas l'ha
comprata da google per 3 miliardi e
mezzo di dollari e questo nest è un
termostato una cosa sembra molto scema
molto semplice da questo termostato in
qualche maniera monitorizza quello che
succede in nel nella casa è adatta alla
temperatura in base ai comportamenti
delle persone impara da noi cosa
facciamo
questa è una stazione meteorologica
casaliga in questa connessa questo per
dirvi che queste tecnologie dove gli
oggetti tutti i giorni diventano
connessi sono diventate una una grande
opportunità questa è una curva che fa
un'azienda chiama gartner che studia un
po l'andamento la doccia l'adozione
della tecnologia questa curva a un picco
di massima diciamo di massi le
aspettative no del hype e in questo
momento l'internet delle cose nella
curva 2014 in cima quella di ricerca c'è
una fortissima aspettativa che questa
tecnologia diventi di grande diffusione
come è stata la curva un momento di
crash in cui a un certo punto la le
tecnologie ci si aspetta troppo a dalle
tecnologie per cui c'è un momento di
qualche mese di delusione però poi
riprendono e diventano realtà economiche
forti e per far vedere questo grafico
questa è una delle tantissime proiezioni
che ci sono per far vedere quanto grande
e diventerà questo internet delle cose
ci pensa te la curva quella più blu
scura sono gli smartphone in termini di
fatturato l'inter tre cose si proietta
che diventi una cosa ancora più grande
ancora più
diciamo importante a questo punto
questo è un mercato dove le aziende
straniere sono presenti me questo è un
grafico fatta da un bel shore capital
americano che contiene tutte le aziende
che in quello estero cercando in questo
momento di fare cose va dalla general
elettric ad aziende microscopiche però
la connettività che noi aggiungiamo agli
oggetti cambia le cose ma non risolve
tutto c'è un problema alla base che per
esempio negli ultimi trent'anni si è
parlato un sacco di questi frigo
connessi a internet non se n'è parlato
tantissimo della casa ideale in frigo
commesso e puri free come se non li
abbiamo
non esistono non ci sono perché oppure
ci sono progetti un po strani no che può
in qualche maniera scappano un po questa
è un dispositivo per suore di clausura
che prende dalle notizie delle frasi che
usano come ispirazione per pregare non
in qualche maniera delle volte non sono
io nel tentativo di essere connessi
forse si perde un po quella necessità di
capire perché facciamo le cose in questo
momento c'è una grande opportunità
secondo me per l'italia in quanto paese
che vive il design in maniera più
intensa di molti altri paesi perché è
uno stato in cui gli ingegneri hanno
capito come si fanno a fare le cose però
molta gente non ho ancora capito il
perché o il come e questa cosa alla
ricerca di significato e una cosa duca
dove i con noi possiamo dare in qualche
maniera un contributivo ha cercato negli
adesso in questi ultimi anni e mezzo di
costruire costruire un po un manifesto
per capire come fare a immaginare quali
sono i parametri che ci permettono di
capire come progettare degli oggetti
connessi che sono legati a dei principi
che non sono solo quelli della
tecnologia più potente e due cose
secondo me sono interessanti da un lato
il design italiano no io qui ho usato
gli esempi dei prodotti di un mio
designer preferito achille castiglioni e
potrete vedere quanti oggetti progettati
da lui sono dilettati dei grandi
classici per cui e lui è solo uno dei
tanti che in italia hanno creato questo
veramente la storia del design e
dall'altro lato sembra strano ma mi sono
ispirato molto allo slow food che a
queste regole
abbastanza semplici su come deve essere
il cibo però in qualche maniera anche la
tecnologia può seguire quest'idea che le
cose devono essere buone pulite e giuste
sicuramente sull'aspetto del buono c'è
questa idea che dobbiamo immaginare un
mondo in cui l'innovazione è più diffusa
dove più persone partecipano a questa
cosa perché il grande problema è che in
questo momento un sacco di dispositivi
che usate voi fanno parte di un mondo
che è progettato in california e
fabbricato in cina
io non sono sicuro che voglio vivere il
mondo in cui tutto è progettato in
california e fabbricato in cina sono
sicura che voglio vivere in un mondo in
cui magari c'è una cosa che è progettata
in india è fabbricata e d'italia
progettata in francia è fabbricata in
america un mondo in cui ci sono molte
più possibilità e questo libro se avete
tempo di leggerlo spiega come si può
aumentare l'accesso all'innovazione a
più persone questo per esempio permette
se noi troviamo degli strumenti per
semplificare la tecnologia per esempio
questo è un progetto che viene dal
giappone che permette che ha permesso
alle persone che vivevano fukushima di
misurare i livelli di radiazione e
capire che lo stato gli stava dicendo
delle informazioni sbagliate perché
hanno potuto costruire dei dispositivi
che prima erano solo professionali
oppure strumenti che rendono appunto
semplice la tecnologia
anche qui quando io lavoravo a questo
interaction design istituti brea ho
lavorato questa idea di intersezione tra
design e tecnologie come re della
tecnologia una cosa che è disponibile a
più persone specialmente ai designer che
sono molto creativi ma non hanno spesso
una preparazione di base tecnologie
siamo inventati questo oggetto questo
arduino questo piccolo computer che sta
alla base di alcuni dei progetti che
avete visto c'è dentro o ardovino stato
usato arduino per progettarli per cui in
qualche maniera
se noi usiamo delle tecnologie aperte
che sono disponibili a tutti noi
possiamo creare un innovazione
distribuita dove tutte le persone
partecipano a dare la loro opinione
perché se nessuno di noi può partecipare
a disegnare il futuro
a questo punto sono poche persone che lo
progettano e ci dicono come vivere
pulito per me vuol dire anche che il
design deve essere una cosa che non si
butta via
adesso un sacco di cose tecnologica noi
buttiamo via invece dobbiamo capire cosa
succede se io voglio costruire dei
prodotti che stanno con le persone per
più tempo molti oggetti di design stanno
con noi per tutta la vita per cui c'è i
prodotti dovrebbero poter vivere e
continuare la tecnologia questo momento
non è particolarmente brava ci sono già
dei siti web dove c'è l'elenco di
oggetti di internet delle cose che non
vivono più che sono morti che non sono
che non funzionano più
perché evidentemente c'è un problema di
queste tecnologie che devono poter
sopravvivere e poi il design tecnologie
dovrebbero essere accessibili a tutti e
non un lusso se se guardiamo presento
questa un esempio la maggior parte le
persone usa un telecomando mai con la
sinistra che fa schifo e quella bestia
con spiegato l'oggetto di lusso ma elisa
non dovrebbe essere solo un oggetto di
lusso deve recuperare quella quella
caratteristica di migliorare in qualche
mese la vita due persone
gli italiani per esempio nel 1972 sono
stati fotografati da questa mostra del
moma in cui in qualche maniera il modo
di vedere l'ambiente domestico dal parte
del design italiano ha rivoluzionato il
modo in cui si immaginano le cose per
cui sicuramente c'è un'opportunità per
l'italia per il design italiano per
capire questa intersezione per capire
come si fanno a progettare qualcosa per
fornire un punto di vista diverso è
giusto è un altro aspetto secondo me è
molto importante a ogni volta che aveva
usate un sito web che è gratuito il
prodotto al sito web siete voi quello
che fate i click che fate i like che
fate le foto del vostro gatto che
postate sono tutte il prodotto per cui
il problema è è possibile fornire magari
un modello alternativo dove non siamo il
prodotto i prodotti connessi sono
collegati con dei servizi on line stallo
su dai siti non sono sicuro che voi
volete che ogni volta che tirate l'acqua
nel vostra toilette
questa informazione viaggi per
interfaccia scatenare migliaia di
software in giro per il mondo che
analizzano perché avete premuto il
pulsante in quel momento questa è una è
una vignetta di un di un fumettista
inglese che fa vedere un supermercato
del futuro in cui la pubblicità dice
ciao john come vanno le emorroidi
perché
però il supermercato ha riconosciuto
alla persona sa che allego radio perché
l'ha cercato su google
a questo punto diventa lo scenario un po
inquietante di una delle persone a
sentirsi sicure che quelle inferiori
informazioni sono non sono utilizzate
contro di loro per esempio uno dei capi
della cia anni fa ha dichiarato vispi e
remo attraverso la vostra lavastoviglie
e questa chiaramente è una cosa
abbastanza inquietante no che gli
oggetti possono rivoltarsi contro di noi
se noi non abbiamo
se non proponiamo un modo diverso da
quello che in questo momento è in
qualche mela fornito dal mercato per
esempio questo anche un semplice
termostato può spiare la nostra vita e
trasformarsi un po come il computer di
odissea nello spazio che in qualche
maniera a un certo punto poi perde un po
il controllo e anche qui un altro
esempio qui dice credo che mia casa stia
andando a fuoco perché google mi sta
offrendo degli estintori e una
sistemazione temporanea per cui in
qualche maniera il termostato avverte
google che cambia la pubblicità sui siti
prima che voi vi accorgiate che la casa
va a fuoco
lui sicuramente questa è la cosa che noi
dobbiamo cercare di di pensare in un
modo diverso possiamo mettere la
bellezza e la capacità del design
italiano a servizio di come noi
interagiamo con le cose e qui infatti se
non a me sono diversi gli scenari
importanti
vi faccio vedere due cose di cui mi sto
occupando io che credo che siano
importanti a questo in questo senso come
arduino ne abbiamo un ufficio a torino
dove abbiamo insieme a bruce sterling e
jasmine atessa novitch immaginato questo
appartamento che sarà tutto che è tutto
diciamo connesse dove gli oggetti sono
connessi però il progetto di questi
oggetti è disponibile su internet per
cui la gente può costruire gli oggetti e
soprattutto vogliamo sperimentare cosa
vuol dire veramente vivere in uno spazio
come questa perché le grandi aziende
fanno le case del futuro ma in queste
case del futuro non ci vivono mai sono
solo delle mostre finte ma invece cosa
succede se effettivamente noi viviamo lì
dentro per cui questo è un posto dove
vogliamo sperimentare nei prossimi anni
e dove vogliamo permettere anche la
gente per esempio di andare su airbnb e
di affittarsi lo per andarci a vivere
una settimana e vedere cosa succede in
un mondo in cui tutto è connesso per cui
la combinazione design italiano
la fabbricazione digitale quindi la
stampa 3d tutte le altre strumentazioni
che abbiamo è la capacità diciamo di
costruire questi oggetti connessi per
cui se volete cioè questo sito casa
jasmine sa è l'ultima cosa che da noi
molto importante la questione della
formazione perché di questi corsi che
effettivamente sono dedicati a questa
intersezione fra il design la tecnologia
in italia ce n'è forse a livello di
master 1 1 a san marino e l'altro ea
lugano dove insegno diciamo nelle
vicinanze dell'italia e in qualche
maniera
credo che il design dei nas ancora
insegnato in maniera troppo
convenzionale troppo legata al passato
per cui quello che è importante in
questo momento è trovare un modo per
ripensare il design e cogliere
l'opportunità che si presenta davanti a
noi l'intersezione fra design e la
tecnologia ci permette di creare delle
cose incredibili
però in questo momento è tutto
appannaggio di gente che il design lo
capisce veramente tanto bene per cui c'è
un'opportunità però bisogna essere un po
diciamo bisogna saltare sulle
opportunità io ho fondato insieme a
altre persone questa fondazione make in
italy con la quale stiamo cercando di
punto di portare il mondo dei maker
italiane in qualche maniera sulla
ribalta internazionale ma anche di
ripensare questo modello educativo
se riusciamo a immaginarci una scuola
che riesce veramente a basarsi
sull'intersezione tra il design e la
tecnologia com'era ivrea che però poi ha
chiuso nel 2006 ma cerca di capire se
appunto possiamo trash prendere questa
grande forza della tradizione italiana
della caccia italiana con la capacità di
pensare alla tecnologia per cui se
riusciamo secondo me avremmo un grande
ne avremo un grande beneficio
grazie